all right so final stage coming up let's
see who we have to face we've already
faced Ganondorf so it's probably not
gonna be him probably master handle
crazy hand what what dude
Ganon what is this son this is awesome
dude why can I not damage him
why can it not damage him I did not
expect this
I mean Ganon is like in Smash Brothers
dude wait what was what was the trick
BOM maybe I'm trying to think of what
was the trick back in oh man what yeah
I'm gonna continue but what was the
trick back in ocarina of time okay we
tried arrows let's try Bom
nope BOM does nothing to him
arrows do nothing at all would you see
that right there maybe I have to hit
that back back at him oh you know what
his tail looks do you have to get behind
him I think you have to get behind him
oh wait it's either okay one of two
things you have to get behind him or
it's the old school where you have to
knock back his in ocarina of time member
how you had to keep hitting like the orb
of light back at him gosh I don't know
if I can get behind him there we go
that's it you got to get behind him are
you kidding me dude
how do you keep getting behind us
oh right there just roll well he's got
an attack to like link where he does the
spin I'm not gonna beat him this time
but we'll just have to use another
continue dude this is awesome though
this was totally unexpected and it's
different it's not just the traditional
keep damage the boss until he's dead
there's actually a little bit of
strategy to this one you have to figure
out how to damage him
oh right there we got him kind of
stunned him a little bit there oh and he
just knocked us off it's all right we
know the secret now I just take that it
drop down the the intensity so many
times so we could have we would have
finished with that one well above nine
had I known the trick before when in
doubt always look for the glowing part
of the boss right oh come on I should
have jumped over him yeah rolling under
him is not it's not quite clean right
there see how you got a
[Music]
and then jumping over him feel like
that's not quite as safe and then by the
time you get over there
oh no that works okay you might be able
to get him this time
[Music]
oh come on I don't want to fight I don't
have to reset it again I wonder if
people like I'm sure people know about
this already but I wonder how many
people know about it because a lot of
people don't even bother with classic
mode you know like yeah we've kind of
seen it all right wrong are you seeing
this Christian if Christian still in the
chat maybe I should have put spoilers I
didn't think you had to worry too much
about spoilers for smash brothers but no
no but like I'm honestly glad I did not
have this spoil for me this is a great
surprise
here we go finishing him off right here
with the final blow let's try to think
who would it be you know we already
fought Ganon we already fought again in
Dorf rather our side don't rub it in
that I can't see dude it was it was like
a full model of of Ganon looked like the
Ganon from Ocarina of Time you know the
pig creature with the horns first it was
Ganondorf and then he just turned into
him right there at the end that totally
caught me off guard I did not expect
that at all that was pretty sweet dude